welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as we transition forward in the
marvel timeline from the universe
breaking events of avengers end game to
the
well even further universe breaking
events of one division it is one
colorful appearance on this disney plus
series that has me the most perplexed
and no not fission but that yellow rock
on his head the mind stone
one of these six infinity stones that
marvel seemed pretty resolute about
being done with even if vision is a kind
of mental projection as opposed to its
former corporeal self we wouldn't need
that infinity stone accessory to know
it's him
clearly the avengers ensuring concluded
that vision could live on without the
mind stones and so should wanda's head
cannon and the infinity stone return is
important for a bigger reason because it
brings us back to that mystery of what
effect exactly these things had on the
universe going forward other than the
ways thanos hulk and tony
intentionally use them yeah we have made
a ton of videos about how
one of those four snaps that we saw
infinity war in an end game could have
had lasting
side effects on things like mutants
but at new details and further research
have now
allowed me to conclude scientifically
yes science
exactly which infinity stone use we need
to look more closely into
and why spoiler warning in case my
theory is right and i
ruin your life okay so this question
bubbled back into my head after we
started to discuss how the infinity
stones presence might still be active in
some way in the mcu
thanks to some bite-sized big questions
asked by our friends flash t-man and
lance pants over on discord avengers end
game
opened with the avengers discovering
that thanos had used these stones again
on its garden planet which
they discovered was for the purpose of
destroying the stones themselves
the universe required correction after
that
the stones serve no purpose beyond
temptation
where are the stones gone reduced to
atoms
you used them two days ago i used the
stones to destroy the stones
it nearly killed me but the work is done
but endgame also kind of created its own
plot hole with the
ancient ones description of the infinity
stones the infinity
stones create what you experience as the
flow of time
remove one of the stones and that flow
splits
now this may benefit your reality but my
new one
not so much in this new branch reality
without our chief weapon against the
forces of darkness
our world would be overrun millions will
suffer
so you know they gathered alternate
versions of the stones from the past
used him to snap everyone back
and snap thanos and his forces dead and
then cap returned
all those stones back in time leaving
the present-day mcu
exactly in the stone-less darkest
timeline that the ancient one warned us
about
whoops these are confusing times but
then after the movie came out the
directors thankfully did a q
a clarifying this plot hole you know
because movies are meant to be three
hour experiences that require
clarification via director q a's and
books and youtube videos to fully
process and appreciate sure anyway they
singled out thanos saying the words
reduced to atoms to explain that thanos
only reduces stones to the atomic level
the stones are still present in the
universe
so according to those guys the universe
maintaining
effects of these stones are still
present that they really just reverted
from
tangible gems to the intangible concepts
of space power reality soul time and
mind still
flowing through the cosmos but that the
stones are no longer in these
quarter-sized rock forms that were
capable of being used and weaponized
that part is never going to happen again
we think you know aside from showing
back up in vision's head or
maybe i guess ant-man shrinking down to
one of those atoms and using it
i'm so confused whatever that's a big
question for another big day
but then not too long ago last summer
marvel further confirmed that the stones
in their stone form are kaput for the
social media posts labeling each stone
as
destroyed but we are left with the russo
brothers explanation that the effects of
those stones remain
an ever thriving ever tinkering ever
evolving force of nature
so how exactly does that effect continue
to
poison this universe well thanks to
science we
finally have answers okay so when we
talk about how the infinity stones work
marvel has given us a specific language
to talk about it with
science from the very beginning these
infinity stones have been classified as
radioactive they emit a specific kind of
radiation
gamma radiation the same kind of
radiation that turned bruce banner into
the incredible hulk which is why
shield worked with banner to use quantum
spectrometers to track the tesseract aka
the space stone back in avengers how
many spectrometers do you have access to
how many others call every lab you know
tell them to put the spectrometers on
the roof and calibrate them for gamma
rays
and then banner reminded us of this link
between infinity stones and gamma
radiation in
endgame but the radiation's mostly gamma
it's like i was made for this flipping
back open your
ap chemistry textbook there gamma
radiation unlike alpha or beta radiation
takes the form of an electromagnetic ray
a supercharged photon blasting off the
radioactive element's nucleus
and striking other nearby matter
disrupting those atomic nuclei
and in the case of organic tissue
causing malfunctions to rna and dna
replication tissue damage and yeah in a
lot of cases cancer but hey in the mcu
it makes you a superhero
yeah applying this science as best we
can at the mcu which i would argue they
want us to do if they're dropping stuff
like plank scale deutsche proposition
epr paradox in their dialogue
that would mean while the radioactive
stones may be gone
the radiation they previously emitted
lingers on in the universe that explains
why carol danvers still has her powers
despite the original source of those
powers a wave
of energy derived from the space stone
that stone is no longer present
or why scarlet witch still has her
powers despite them being activated by
the mind stone
it's not the stone itself it's the
radiation that comes off the stone
and this is important because when we're
talking about energy there's another
concept in physics that we have to
keep in mind called the law of
conservation of energy which states that
the total energy of an isolated system
remains constant that energy can neither
be created nor destroyed
it can only be transformed or
transferred from one form to another so
that means that the total energy the
infinity stones contained
must have transferred somewhere and
taken new forms the moment they were
destroyed by thanos
that is why when we look at those four
snaps of infinity war and end game and
speculate on other possible side effects
we gotta look at that second one the one
in which thanos destroyed the stones
reducing them to
atoms in his words but in the form of a
shock wave that's spread out from that
garden planet and registered on rocket
sensors
every other time those stones energy was
redirected to a specific thing that we
saw happen
universe-wide dustings or reversing the
dusting
something that would have required a
[ __ ] ton of energy to do
so law of conservation of energy makes
sense there bounces out except this one
time when the stones were destroyed that
energy just
spilled somewhere we didn't see what it
did and assuming
that shock wave was made of gamma
radiation
according to that law of thermodynamics
all of the cosmic energy contained in
those six stones the ability to
teleport to telekinetically move matter
to fire energy blasts through mind
control
to create time loops to manipulate all
of reality
all of that must have transferred
somewhere
maybe into some one or some ones and
that is why this remains such an
important potential clue explaining
how groups like the mutants could
suddenly exist in the mcu mutants whom
we know from comics can teleport
can telekinetically move matter and fire
energy blasts can mind control
can manipulate time in reality now if
you've watched past videos you know that
i've wagered small numbers of mutants
might have already existed before
all this with people born with a natural
dormant x
gene explaining why the maximoff twins
were chosen for experimentation to begin
with that relatively new wakandaphile's
book
made it very clear that the x gene plus
infinity stone radiation
yields powers but this universe-wide
floodgate of gamma radiation was a
unique
one-time event that according to the
russos had lasting consequences
at least at an atomic level therefore
the full destructive
power of the infinity stones despite no
longer being capable of being wielded in
stone form
nonetheless must have been according to
science redistributed in the mcu's
greatest trade-off
and a new wave of superheroes may have
just awoken
ooh by the way if you like this shirt it
is one of many amazing options available
for purchase at our new merch store
newrockstarsmerch.com
we got hoodies jackets masks all kinds
of great original nerdy designs
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
at eavos follow me rockstars thank you
for watching
[Music]
you